so you used to go to like the Marianne
Williamson lectures well there was this
book and I always forget the name of the
book that she teaches from South says he
thinks the books called what do you
think it's called Sal
you ran Chia your ran gee so that's the
disease on your balls so yes it's a
Course in Miracles your branch oh I love
that weird way to tell get your ranch or
from it's gonna be further from A Course
in Miracles how do you think it's called
the Ranchi a book it's an interpretation
of how the earth was created you read
that Sal yeah I'm reading it it
basically there was a bunch of guys back
in the day spirits came down aliens came
down and they explained how the earth
was created let me ask you something if
you're gonna read a book why would you
read up a book mine's a book once you
read a book on history or something that
was based in science this is history
this this is tied into science this is
no bubu meister stuff howard brutal
meister they don't even know who wrote
it
there's nobody nobody claims to have
written it yeah remember when Klaatu
were the Beatles yes I think they wrote
it sound good he's the boss all right
tell me what it is it's a book on how
the earth was created how we got here
and it was created by aliens to a degree
was created by God who sent down what we
might define them as aliens but they
were spirit forms and they came down and
they dropped certain portions of DNA why
would you believe that like why wouldn't
you believe a scientist who says you
know that there was a cosmic boom the
cosmic boom that you're speaking of
plays a part in you Ranchod but there's
a many more elements to it what was
wrong with Catholicism's explanation
this is better than Cavell right this is
not a monster it's a bubble mind sir
whatever and you read the whole book the
books 2100 pages on every getting read I
read portions of it I've been gonna
watch you've been researching in other
words you read the cliff notes
it's an amazing book you read the book
Michael you stick to the Dead Sea
Scrolls where the original language and
how have you not read it and you think
it's incredible well again I browse
through and I've researched it it's a
love that he says he researched but he
doesn't even know how to research what
do you mean you research it's an
intricate book and there's a lot of big
words and it gets a little complicated
why would you listen to a scientist over
like a guy who anonymously wrote a book
well science is combined in this there
are there are scientists that have
validated this book who I don't know
specifically do you believe in man-made
global warming you know how I thought
about global warming in the past I said
you know whatever we're spraying stuff
into the air and this and that and
nothing's going to change I take all
that back after you've reading your
Antje because the universe was created
for us and we in turn have to respect
the universe so when we do these things
we're saying [ __ ] you to the universe
we're saying [ __ ] you to the people who
have provided us with so much so now I
make an effort to do everything I can to
preserve the universe and that's what I
learned through your ranch what do you
do well I really know I recycle okay
that's the law that's so what if it's a
law you probably break the law all the
time what do you do that's different
than everyone else what I'm doing my
part I'm trying
what are you doing it well if I see
garbage on the ground even in the city I
pick it up I put it in the garbage pail
I make sure that I separate recyclable
stuff versus recyclables mentioned three
times recycling are you separating glass
and paper are you recycling
I'm recycling separate I do it both I
even go down to the recycle places
recycling is separated yeah what's
separate but then I take the extra
effort I go down to the in other words
after reading your aunt Rhea you not
only separate